نذهب الى وليد العمري
وليد قبل قليل ذكرنا ما نقل عن ديوان
رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه من ان نتنياهو
طالب الوزراء في حكومته بعدم التعليق
بتاتا على عمليه اغتيال صالح العاروري
ماذا في
التفاصيل هذا الموقف من جانب نتنياهو جاء
معتاد لانه سيبقي الامر له شخصيا كي يقوم
بالاعلان والتعليق اولا ثم يلونه في هذه
القضيه في اسرائيل وان كانوا رسميا حتى
الان لا يتحدثون عن اغتيال العاروري ومن
معه في الضاحيه الجنوبيه في بيروت لكن من
ردات الفعل الكثيره سواء على صعيد وسائل
الاعلام او ما جاء في تغريده لوزير المال
سموتريتش وغيره فواضح
بانهم مبتهجون جدا لعمليه الاغتيال ويرون
فيها انها انجاز كبير حيث يصفون العاروري
بانه كان المستهدف رقم واحد بالنسبه
لاسرائيل من قبل الحرب وخلال هذه الحرب
يشيرون اليه الى انه قد يكون الشخصيه
الاهم لانه ايضا يشرف على فعاليات ونشاطات
القسام في الضفه الغربيه ومتهم بانه حاول
تحريك الضفه لكن هناك جانب اخر ايضا كان
يقلقهم ان العاروري كان من الشخصيات
القياديه الفلسطينيه التي تعمل من اجل
الوحده في الشارع الفلسطيني وعمل كثيرا من
اجل ان يكون هناك مصالحه بالتعاون مع
مسؤولين حتى كبار من حركه فتح مثل جبريل
جوب وغيره لكن الان ما يجري في اسرائيل هو
ان نتنياهو اراد من وزرائه ان يصمتوا علما
ان كل التصريحات السابقه في الايام
الماضيه والشهر الماضي والذي سبقه كان
دائما يتحدث عن ان الاغتيالات قادمه
ونتنياهو سبق له ان قال بانه اوعز وامر
جهاز الموساد بان يقوم ببدء عمليات اغتيال
ضد قاده حركه حماس في كل مكان بما في ذلك
في الخارج ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ال في
نهايه الشهر الماضي هو الاخر المحى الى ان
اسرائيل تبيت عمليه اغتيال كما يبدو في
بيروت وسبق هؤلاء جميعا ايضا ان القرارات
التي صدرت ومنذ بدايه الحرب على غزه بعد
طوفان الاقصى جميع كانت توحي بان اسرائيل
في مرحله من مراحل هذه الحرب ستبدا
بعمليات اغتيال تستهدف القاده الكبار
والكوادر الاخرى في حركه حماس خارج البلاد
وليس بالضروره ان تكون في قطاع غزه والضفه
الغربيه فقط وكانت بيروت تذكر بهذا السياق
الان يرى الاسرائيليون الامر كالتالي
يقرونه على
ان الامين العام لحزب الله نصر الله على
مترق طرق اما ان يهدئ من الاوضاع في جنوب
لبنان او ان يفجر حربا شامله بمعنى انهم
لا يريدون لحرب الاستنزاف التي فتحها حزب
الله منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه ان تستمر
وكان قد سبقت دعوات كثيره في اسرائيل تقول
بانهم يجب ان يشنوا عمليات وان يصعدوا
ويوجهوا ضربات الايام الاخيره شهدت تصعيدا
في التصريحات واللهجه الاسرائيليه وكانوا
يدعون الى انه يجب ابعاد حزب الله الى ما
وراء خط نهر الليطاني اي بعمق يصل الى نحو
40 كيلومتر في لبنان الان مع هذا الاغتيال
في العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت ويعتبر تطورا
لافتا وربما مفصليا اسرائيل بطبيعه الحال
هي في حاله تاهب قصوى لكنها ما اقدمت هذه
العمليه واضح من تفاصيلها بان من قام بها
يملك هذا السلاح والذخيره القادره على ان
تقتل من في داخل شقه دون ان تهدم باقي
العماره وهذا السلاح معروف ان لدى اسرائيل
منه الكثير واستخدمته بالماضي نعم وهنا
ربما السؤال معلومات ليست بالامر العسير
نعم معلومات ليست بالامر العسير وهي
معلومات اوصلتها الى الكثير من الاهداف
وليد اذا حاولنا ان نستذكر عمليات اغتيال
سابقه يعني استهدفت في ماليزيا تم اغتيال
قيادي شاب من حماس في دبي تم اغتيال
المبحوح اي حاولت ايضا اغتيال اسامه حمدان
سنه 2009 بارسال طرد له ولكنه نجى لان
مرافقيه هم من فتحوا هذا الطرد اذا هناك
محاولات كثيره وهذا يعني ان قيادات حماس
كلها تحت
المجهر ليس حماس وحده هذه حلقه جديده
اسرائيل منذ نشاه الثوره الفلسطينيه وهي
تقوم بعمليات ومسلسلات اغتيالات
متواصله دون انقطاع ضد القياديين وضد
المفكرين وضد المؤثرين على الساحه
الفلسطينيه وبيروت تحديدا شهدت اكبر قدر
من عمليات الاغتيال التي نفذتها اسرائيل
ضد قياديين فلسطينيين الان في هذه المرحله
هي تستهدف قاده حماس وكتائب القسام على
وجه الخصوص واذا ما عدنا الى ما علق به
خبير الشؤون الاستخباراتيه الاسرائيلي
يوسي ميلمان الذي قال بانه قبل ان يتاكد
موضوع ان العاروري هو المستهدف قال انه
اذا تاكد بان العاروري هو المستهدف فان
هذا سيكون عملا مشتركا للموساد ولجهاز
الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاسرائيلي وهذا تقريبا مؤشر كيف
تعمل هذه الدوله